[SPEAKER_01]: Morning of the Fourth of Well, Son.
[SPEAKER_01]: That morning, Folsum and Tyrus were pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge had had his usual night at heavy drinking and Merrick, through his heightened wisdom,
[SPEAKER_01]: Had only enough to seem as if he was drinking with the rest of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he kept his head about him and he kept his eye on the bowl, which was basically all in black.
[SPEAKER_01]: So early that morning on the 4th,
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge and Merrick decided to help their two buddies up off the floor at Bird's Bar, which by the way, ew, that is ew.
[SPEAKER_02]: They probably both had to work to help me out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably took them both to get me out.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's pretty fucking gross.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you retrace your subs through the foreign district back to the harbor to find Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: There were some words exchanged.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not that Folsum or Tyrus really remember all of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: The upshot of it was Owen Black was ready to return to Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if the four of you agreed to come with him, well then, he would leave his old crew, which he was not very happy with in the first place, and bring the four of you on as his new crew.
[SPEAKER_01]: As it were now.
[SPEAKER_01]: The way he explained it was, with Merrick and him, running the boats so they could move twice as fast, he trusted no other man more than Merrick at the helm and basically to navigate the waters around the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they could go both day and night, not worrying about the tide or the rocks or any of the reefs around the islands themselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: He welcomed you aboard his little ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the Sloof's deck plant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, it's about 70 feet long.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's got a couple of cabins in the back, three, so two of you had to sleep on the deck.
[SPEAKER_01]: But more likely, what it would be is somebody would be piloting up on the top, and the other one would be manning the sails.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hot rocket, basically, is what it was, back and forth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dumping their hungover friends in the cabins, the sloop made it out of the docks at 10 a.m. that day, heading towards the open ocean, well, Jirley Bay, as it were, and towards whatever adventures you guys had coming in your direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you leave
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Slipping out of the harbor district into the sea and basically, you and Owen Black are up on the steerage deck with gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you head out into the sea and head towards the east, not up through the Straits of Monmurg towards Red Shore directly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of interesting that he's piloting you this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go ahead and have dialogue now.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the long direction that we have to go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are we going all the way around and out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why are we going that way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where are we going?
[SPEAKER_00]: East?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we're going out.
[SPEAKER_01]: That way, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean to make for the gap between Folsom Island and Jetsam Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we go straight through the Straits of Monmurg, who knows what Keog patrol will run into.
[SPEAKER_01]: I found that these waters, there are no patrols.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick, you know the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I mean to do is navigate by the Dragon Isles.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to tell you, friends, no ship goes there, but I haven't seen the dragons there lately.
[SPEAKER_01]: It used to be a harrowing journey to take, but as of late, no sign of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you seen anything there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Any movement of any life there?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know the dragon islands, they're pretty much barren.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's fish around them, and quite so.
[SPEAKER_01]: The coral reef's beautiful over there, but the islands themselves are just two rocks.
[SPEAKER_01]: None of the moving islands you normally see nearby.
[SPEAKER_01]: The dragons themselves, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seems like we're just playing a lottery game then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus says as he walks onto the deck, holding his head.
[SPEAKER_00]: Need a poll?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good.
[SPEAKER_00]: What time of day is it right now?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's about 10, 1030.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the weather like?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a very, very sunny day, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where are we approaching right now?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're like right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right there?
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going to go through here?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to go past here and up through here and around.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's about 50 miles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This ship goes around three miles an hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three and a half.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three miles an hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: To win with us or against us?
[SPEAKER_01]: It actually is going northerly, which is good enough because you guys have sails that can take that and you head east.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're adding about another three or four days to make our way all the way around instead of going straight up for the safety of keeping away from patrols.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not going to be that long, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to be going 24 hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a feeling that we'll probably make the Dragon Isles in a day, day and a half, and then on to Red Shore after that is just half a day's journey.
[SPEAKER_00]: Believe me, this is the safer route.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's also a day or a day and a half to get rid of this headache.
[SPEAKER_00]: When was the last time you ran this route?
[SPEAKER_00]: A few weeks ago.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's safer in one way, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: More dangerous than others than if that's the case.
[SPEAKER_02]: A little curiosity is why nothing's been seen out here now.
[SPEAKER_01]: This way used to be worse when the Commodores of Flotsam and Jetsam cared about the oceans around here.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, one small sloop they usually care not about.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even though they have men watching the Gap,
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think they're going to care.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their eyes are pointed northward more towards Keoland than anything else now.
[SPEAKER_01]: And their ships are in their bays, so it's doubtful they'll send anyone out towards us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we just surrounded by water now, or can I see any land from the... Oh, you see Flotsam Island, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see Monmurg behind you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to look over the side and just...
[SPEAKER_00]: To see if I see anything, just to... because I am uneasy after the last experience.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, roll a perception check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perception, I meant... What would I roll for that?
[SPEAKER_01]: So what is your perception?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a skill.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you roll a 20-sided die and add six to it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then space off your wisdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you see something floating off in the water, probably about...
[SPEAKER_01]: 300 yards away that looks strange to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're heading towards it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're probably right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, you see that we're heading towards?
[SPEAKER_00]: You see that fling floating out there?
[SPEAKER_00]: We're approaching it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your eyes are a little red.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll perception.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have my contact.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd rather see you die.
[SPEAKER_02]: 1624.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a body.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a body afloat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen, can we steer the boat?
[SPEAKER_00]: I see a body.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're approaching it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we steer the boat right next to it and slow it down a little bit?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to inspect this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to know if there's any danger, if there's anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Always a responsible man.
[SPEAKER_01]: He angles the boat so it goes towards him.
[SPEAKER_01]: In about, I would say, five minutes you guys come up along it and do you want to take a bell hook and like hook the body?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll grab the hook, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: For a second you think maybe, hmm, is it possible this is Lord Fairwind?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who...
[SPEAKER_02]: I just load my crossbow while there's
[SPEAKER_01]: You blow your crossbow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll hook the body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Tyrus gets out the billhook and hooks the body and brings it up towards...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a sahagin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bloated, obviously been in the water for a day or so.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gills, bright red, and they look like they're blistered.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's from the shit we put in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I let it go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seems to be working wonders.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus unhooks the thing and it floats into the sea, basically, and continues to float as you guys go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this kind of around where it let all that shit out?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's Helm's Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the water comes this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: So obviously it has floated into Jirley Bay from the Azur sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Owen doesn't know about any of that stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he doesn't know about any of that stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Keep moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you continue to sail and actually as the hours pass by and you keep watch, you see more and more of those bodies floating in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just do work.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just want to work the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you work the sails, you do what not.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it seems like there were quite a few that died in the area around when you guys put the stuff in.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sahuagin were definitely massing for something else from Helms Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: You killed, if not hundreds of them, maybe even thousands.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who knows?
[SPEAKER_01]: That doesn't bode well at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys continue to sail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus works the sales.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsum, basically, after recovering from his bad hangover about midday, begins to play his fife to keep you entertained.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what do you guys want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just kind of hang on the boat?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, Merrick's keeping a watch on stuff, so size seems to be a little sharper than mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll relax while I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, do you have any liquor on you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could you spare a drink or two?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to try to get Owen's lips moving.
[SPEAKER_00]: Untie his tongue a little bit as we sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no problem with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I feel like he knows something that could be of value to me and to us.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have my flask.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are they untied?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I hear them?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he wanted to do this as an aside.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, I'd pull it back from him, take a swig, and give it to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd roll my eyes and put it in my bucket.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I go up to... Where's Owen on the deck, I assume?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's on the steerage right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen, you mind if I take steerage for a little bit?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's been up here for a while.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're only two hours out of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can still see Helms Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, I could do with some company.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, I'm going to ask you this question.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to have this conversation in private?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just going to do little pricks and prods, I'm not going to deep dive into anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you want the answers to yourself as opposed to us, in case you hear something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you care just to have a conversation and the rest of the crew can kind of hear it?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you guys are just not part of the conversation, but you're within earshot, because this boat is not that big.
[SPEAKER_00]: I pull the flask out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mimic taking a sip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen, drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Some of the finest liquor that I got back from...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is red-eye!
[SPEAKER_01]: I gag a little.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn, we could do better than that!
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't, Folsum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, go down to the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go down to the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a crate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Finest, Toli, rung.
[SPEAKER_01]: Black bottles.
[SPEAKER_01]: Black is your heart, boy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Black is my last name.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I snap and look up at you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Toss it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you go into the back cabin and there's a crate of what he said where those bottles, they are clear at the top but the liquid inside is a dark
[SPEAKER_01]: Black liquid.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't really have an idea how this could be considered the finest, but Toli Rum is notorious for how horrible it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, you bring the bottles back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hand it to Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I say, here you are, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Great, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll love this stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is all we have to drink, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: After your performance last night, nobody would touch Toli Rum.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought I could sell it, but this is what we get.
[SPEAKER_03]: Their loss is our gain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me hand it to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Owen, it's been quite a while since we conversed last... Have a nice piss off the back of the deck?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're good.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's life been dealing you lately?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, life has been dealing me good hands, as you can see.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I told you the stories last night.
[SPEAKER_01]: My adventures in Salinmore, how I got this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He holds up his hand that has a kind of a cast, a splint on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to tell you, I've been dealing with some very, very important men, I must say.
[SPEAKER_01]: I told Tyrus all this yesterday.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Baywin beat me, took me to Appleyard Keep, stuck me down in there and I was able to escape with the help of some friendly bugbears.
[SPEAKER_01]: Escaped off to this place called Turtle Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Never heard of a friendly bugbear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eh, well, you want to meet this dwarf.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, after meeting that beast, me and the bugbears made a good deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: We were able to escape.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, Owen, been up to a lot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Made quite a bit of money, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, we're gonna be there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the ship's sailing pretty slow.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if you care to share any stories on your adventures, I'd like to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, I mean... Like I told you boys...
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes a lot of the drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's quite a bit of money in Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have an employer who I've worked on and off for for the last three months, two or three months, doing business for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mostly transporting personnel from here to there and so on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you seem to be doing pretty well for yourself, probably a pretty important employer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty well off?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kane Toli himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Moving men, weapons, up in the salt marsh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Up to the strange folk in the swamps.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't go that far.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's how I know the bugbears, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: They take the weapons farther north.
[SPEAKER_00]: How is it transporting Toli men?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know they can be a little rambunctious sometimes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you'll see a lot of Toli rats in Redshore.
[SPEAKER_01]: They seem to have quite a presence there, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Plar of Selinmore, I hear, doesn't allow them in his towns anymore, however.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though there's some in Seton.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know the Toli rats go wherever the money is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, you seem to follow as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not comparing you to a rat, but you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have a little bit more quality than they do, I would like to think.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would agree, I would agree.
[SPEAKER_01]: But no, maybe I could introduce you to King Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I found that quite interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we'd have a lot to come and a lot to talk about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's actually got a small fleet for himself that he
[SPEAKER_01]: He's parked out on that island in the middle of the bay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, maybe we can make better pay there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you'd like the work he'd give you, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah?
[SPEAKER_01]: He seems to have pulled back a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was all over selling more Apple Yard Keep until Laplar showed up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Laplar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Balin is what they call him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's taken over Selenmore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Duke of Gratzel gave him the fiefdom for some reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rumor is he was going after a cult of necromancers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen any of it myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, not a fan of those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lighten the feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Folsum, you tell me, what was that you were singing last night?
[SPEAKER_03]: What I was singing was, you know, just the usual, right off the top of my head, but it was what I believe.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you believe that Sac Nontoli has betrayed us?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean... You believe that the princes are fighting each other?
[SPEAKER_03]: I believe there is discourse and things that shouldn't be happening definitely happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: But Folsum, I also know you like to exaggerate a little bit with your songs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, of course.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I'm trying to...
[SPEAKER_03]: To fester up a crowd, get a reaction, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: So how did you come into this knowledge, by the way?
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you talking about the whore?
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, I just...
[SPEAKER_03]: Again, it was just more like trying to rally up and get people to think, you know, rather than really say, spout the knowledge of what's going on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, if there's truth to it, there's more money to be made.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's nothing like playing princes off against each other to make a good piece of coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, if you have any specific knowledge, I'd love to hear it.
[SPEAKER_03]: To be truthful with you,
[SPEAKER_03]: I ain't got nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe we'll hear more of it in your song.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't want to give it away, do you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want the final act, the real uppercut.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got to pay for information like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe Kane Tully would pay for it quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: It might be interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Quite eager to meet this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I grab my fife and just start playing.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys keep sailing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there anything else you really want to ask the guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not for the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the arrows go on and Owen does what he always does, which is basically babbles about this or that, the coastline.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rumors he's heard, outrageous stories of this crimson pirate or the red rat, as he's called, that had burned Port Torben.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says he's nothing but a boy and actually a fraud, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: He tells a lot of other crazy stories about
[SPEAKER_01]: Hobgoblins on Turtle Island and that he had actually ferried many of them to the Appleyard Keep himself before basically his ship was taken away by the claw.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, he said, but I stole it back.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he points to the ship that they're on, even though it was a little worse for wear.
[SPEAKER_01]: He points down to the deck near Tyrus and says, See that burn scorch there?
[SPEAKER_01]: I had no idea how it got there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was out of my possession for about a month.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was kind of stranded on Red Shore until Kane totally gave it back to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He said he had a job for me to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: How'd you lose it?
[SPEAKER_01]: I told you the plaw beat me up and took it away from me.
[SPEAKER_02]: He got it back for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kane Tully got it back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apparently he captured the ship back.
[SPEAKER_01]: There was some old sailor that was trying to sail back to Saltmarsh from Kane Tully's island.
[SPEAKER_01]: He caught him on the wind before he could make it there.
[SPEAKER_01]: An old sailor, huh?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I hear the man's in prison on the island now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Huh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, how fortuitous.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe you could write a song about me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, it's already in the works.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, good to know.
[SPEAKER_03]: With all these stories, everyone should know the tales of Owen Blackwell.
[SPEAKER_03]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get it right.
[SPEAKER_01]: My apologies.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know how I...
[SPEAKER_01]: The Blackwell family is a good family.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Monmurg, good traders.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can understand why you would make the mistake.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: For how noble him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yup.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyway, the day goes on.
[SPEAKER_01]: You basically sail for...
[SPEAKER_01]: Mom?
[SPEAKER_04]: Hey!
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten hours.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hi!
[SPEAKER_04]: How are you guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: Good.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um...
[SPEAKER_04]: You move ten feet per round faster and actually you move four miles per hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was just taking pictures of all my spells so I don't have to dig for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, eight hours later, you guys have gone about 26 miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you are passing the small island off the coast of Flossum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably another four before you start into the channel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen Black says, he's done, he's gonna turn in, you've got the helm for eight hours, and he goes to bed.